TO THE MADE. FIFTY ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE BILLS TO CONSIDER-
THIS MORNING BEFORE WE BEGAN A
FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BERMAN. AND HOLD THEN
I'M FOR COVERING VACANCIES
TODAY AND I'M WELCOME MISS
WEBER WHO IS NOW A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT
ALWAYS LIKE NEW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEE WHAT WE'LL TESTER
OUT SEE IF YOU CAN KEEP UP I
KNOW SHE CAN I KNOW SHE CAN WE
ARE KEEPING A PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN- THE CHAMBERS TODAY IF YOUR
IN HERE YOU HAVE TO WEAR A
MASK- YOU HAVE TO BUY BY OUR
RULES IF YOU CALL IN- WE BY BY
VERY STRICT RULES HERE SO IF
YOU CANNOT- SIMPLY ABIDE BY
THOSE RULES WE WILL CUT YOU
OFF- THAT INCLUDES JUST STATING
IF YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS- YOU
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE BILL FOR
UP TO TWO MINUTES I'D HAVE TO
HAVE- YOUR TEST MIGHT HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE FINANCIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THE BILL. IF
YOU ARE NOT THE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OUR JUST GIVING SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION WE EXPECT YOU TO SAY
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IF
YOU HAVE ONE- AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
ANYTHING BEYOND THAT OR
ANYTHING OUT THE ORDINARY WILL
BE CUT OFF BECAUSE OF OBVIOUSLY
ONE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN BILLS
WE COULD BE HERE ALL DAY- WITH
THAT EVERYBODY'S WEARING MASKS.
I WEAR MASKS- THE CALL IN LINE
FOR TESTIMONY IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. THE CALL INFORMATION IS
ALSO AVAILABLE ON THE DAILY
FILE AND IN THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. YEAH PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2081 OF MY STAFF WILL
TRY TO HELP YOU OUT. WE ALSO
ACCEPT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE COMMITTEES EMAIL
SYSTEM AND THROUGH THE POSTAL
SERVICE EVEN IF WE ARE HERE THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AND WITH THAT I THINK
WE HAVE A QUORUM CAN WE CALL
WORLD. I'M SECRETARY. PRESIDENT
PRESENT. CORREO IT'S GREAT
CHECK OUT. DALY DAVIES FONG
GABRIEL THE WORKERS HERE LIVING
WORK ROBERT RIVAS WEBER. HOLDEN
BERMAN. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH- IN ORDER THE PEOPLE
SHOWED UP BUT IF YOU'RE WAITING
AND WATCHING THIS IN THE BILL
GETS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
IN THE MEMBER WAVES
PRESENTATION YOU WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION AT THE END OF THE
MEETING AND PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
WITH THAT WE WILL START WITH.
MR COOLEY- AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
ENJOYS A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION. I DON'T THINK
THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW A SECOND BY MISS
CALDERON. MISS YOUR COOLEY
CALLERS MADAM CHAIR THIS BILL
SIMPLY UPDATES A GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE OF THE CIRCLE
REGIONAL TRANSIT AGENCY IT
MAKES IT A ONE PERSON ONE VOTE
THIS REFLECTS THE FACT THAT ONE
AGENCY HAS JUST BEEN A
FINANCIAL PARTICIPANT IS NOW A
FULL MEMBER FOR JUST A PDATES
ARE REGISTER VOTING SYSTEM THE
REQUESTED I VOTE. I BELIEVE
THERE IS A WITNESS ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. HI GOOD MORNING
MANAGER. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOE FULL
BORE HA I AM HERE REPRESENTING
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT-
VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TIME
THAT'S WHAT THE AUTHORS TIME
FOR TAKING ON. ARTICLE BY-
SECRETARY BANNED LIFELINE OF
THE- TECH REGION WE- A LOT OF
SERVICES DURING KOBE AND WITH
THE ANNEXATION OF ALL GROW- WE
NO LONGER FEEL THAT- A COMPLEX
WEIGHTED VOTING SYSTEMS
NECESSARY PLEASE WE STRIVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT- WE HAVE. A-
REGIONAL AND EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF OUR SERVICES
AND WE DON'T INTEND TO SEEK ANY
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE STATE
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE
MINOR OBSERVABLE COST. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
AND LEAD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU- WE WILL I SEE
NOBODY IN THE CHAMBERS OF HER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
IF YOU ARE CALLING- IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION WITH ALL. AB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. STATE YOUR
POSITION ON AIM BE ELEVEN
NINETY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. TO HELP ONLINE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WE HAVEN'T WE
HAVEN'T ALIGNED IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU MR FRATER- YOU HAVE A
THE MOTION AND A SECOND MISTER
COOLEY. THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH THE CHAIR VOTING NOW.
AT YOU CAN PRESENT AB TWELVE
NINETY THREE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW A SECOND BY
MISS CALDERON. THIS AB TWELVE
R. THREE SIMPLY CONFORMS THE
JUDGE'S RETIREMENT SYSTEM TO
PERMIT INCOME TESTING I GUESS
PERIODICALLY- RELEASED AN INDEX
FEDERAL GUIDELINES IT REFLECTS
SIMILAR TREATMENT OTHER
RETIREES IN CALIFORNIA. I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME MEDICARE THANK
YOU AND THERE IS NO WITNESS SO
WE'LL JUST GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE NINETY
THREE. THE STATE YOUR POSITION
ON AB TWELVE NINETY THREE PRESS
ONE OR ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN.
ZERO FOR TWELVE NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. WONDERFUL BRINGING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
COOLEY. THANK YOU. MEETING ON
MISS QUICK SILVA. SHE YOU HAVE
AB SEVEN THIRTY. IT ENJOY THE
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION AND BY MISTAKE THE
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AB SEVEN THIRTY
IS A MEASURE TO PROTECT
CHILDREN IN PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
BY CREATING CLEAR GUIDELINES
FOR THEIR AGENTS THAT ALIGN
WITH EXISTING PROTECTIONS FOR
MINORS AND ENTERTAINMENT.
SIMPLY THIS WOULD MATCH WHAT IS
IN STATUE FOR YOUNG ACTORS AND-
PROFESSIONAL YOUNG ACTORS ANY
WOULD MAKE THE SAME.
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR NOW YOUNG
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES ARE UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN IT WOULD
ALSO INDICATE THAT THERE HAS TO
BE A GUARDIAN. OR PARENT OR THE
COACH COULD STEP IN IF THE
MINOR IS TO BE TAKEN TO ANY
TYPE OF- VENUE THAT WOULD SERVE
ALCOHOL OR SO FORTH. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FORCED AN AYE
VOTE WE HAVE NO WITNESSES-
MISTER OPERATOR AB SEVEN THIRTY
OF THE COLORS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. KEEP THE STATE
POSITION ON THIS BILL PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO
TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON AB
SEVEN THIRTY. THERE NO LINE TO
GET THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO COMMENT THAT
GETS OUT ON A RATE BY A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISS CREEK SILVA.
NEXT WE HAVE MR STONE. MR STONE
AB. SIX SIXTEEN. WE HAVE ASIAN
BY IS CALDERON A SECOND BY I'M
DOCTOR QUIRK. SECOND BY DR
CORRECT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB SIX ONE
SIX REALLY ADDS A BILL BY MAIL
OPTION FOR FARMWORKERS
ELECTIONS I UNDERSTAND A. O. R.
B. AS A TERM THE COST TO BE
ABSORBED WILL AND I ASK FOR
YOUR I. THE- THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A WITNESS MARIO
MARTINEZ FROM- THE UFW GENERAL
COUNSEL I'M ASSUMING HE'S ON
THE LINE ANSWERING GENERAL ANY
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY.
CORRECT YES GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MARIO MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS BILL
AND I'M ON THE PHONE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANKS THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SIX
SIXTEEN. THE STATE YOUR
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOU GET UP
ONLINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BOTTOM LINE. BUT LINE.
FIFTY
SEVEN FIVE. ADDITION OF AB.
THIRTEEN OH FOUR. STATE YOUR
POSITION ON A P. THIRTEEN ON
FOR HIS FIRST ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO FOUR BILL
AB. THIRTEEN ZERO FOUR.
INTERLINING QB JUST MOMENTS.
BUT A LINE OF LINE NUMBER FORTY
SIX FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS. THAT BILLS ON
CALL THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ GOT A COUPLE
BILLS. LET'S START WITH AB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW IN A SECOND
BY DR COURT. ME PROCEED THANK A
MENTOR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE WHICH
REQUIRE EACH INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER LEARNING TO COLLECT
PACIFIC INFORMATION FROM CAMPUS
RECOGNIZED FOR ATTORNEYS M.
SORORITIES THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE INSTITUTIONS UNDER A
NEWLY PUBLICIZED INFORMATION
COLLECTED INCLUDING THE NUMBER
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT INCIDENTS
ON THE SCHOOL WEBSITE AND
DISTRIBUTE THAT INFORMATION VIA
CAMPESINA AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR
RECRUITS INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
WHICH ISN'T TO KEEP OUR
STUDENTS SAFE. THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES DO
WE HAVE- SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR- BILL AB
FIVE TWENTY FOR ME PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR
PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. BERNAL LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT BRINGING THAT BACK I SEE
NO QUESTIONS IT HAS THE MOTION
SECOND PACKETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL AB FIVE
FIFTY ONE IT ENJOYS A DEAL
PASSED RECOMMENDATION I SEE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK. YOU MAY BE
SEATED. THANK RAMPS ARE MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB
FIVE FIVE ONE. AB FIVE FIVE ONE
WOULD AUTHORIZE COASTERS TO
OFFER AND ACCEPT CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR TRADITIONAL TAX DEFERRED
IRA. AND ROTH IRA PLANS
INCLUDING ROLLOVERS FROM ANY
ELIGIBLE RETIREMENT PLAN. WITH
ME TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IS MERRY AND ASHLEY WITH THE
COASTERS AND JENNIFER BAKER
WITH CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
SO THE WITNESSES ON THE FRONT
LINE STARTING WITH MARION
ASHLEY. HI GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
MARIANN ASHLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM CHARACTERS IS
THE SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE.
CHARACTERS MISSION SECURING THE
FINANCIAL FUTURE AND SUSTAINING
THE TRUST OF CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATORS. WE OFFER HYBRID
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS DEFINED
BENEFIT CASH BALANCE AND
VOLUNTARY DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
PLANS. AND WHILE THE DEFINED
BENEFIT PLAN IS A GREAT BENEFIT
FOR CALIFORNIA TEACHERS IT
CURRENTLY WILL ONLY REPLACE
ABOUT 50% OF A MEMBERS END OF
CAREER EARNINGS. IN ADDITION
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATORS DO NOT CONTRIBUTE TO
SOCIAL SECURITY. SO THEY WILL
NOT RECEIVE A SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFIT FOR THE CALPERS COVERED
EMPLOYMENT. THAT'S CHARACTERS
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE FOR
MEMBERS TO HELP SUPPLEMENTAL
RETIREMENT SAVINGS AND REALLY
ENCOURAGES OUR MEMBERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN A SUPPLEMENTAL
RETIREMENT SAVINGS PLAN.
CURRENTLY CHARACTERS OFFERS
BIRTH TO D. FOR FIFTY SEVENTY
ROCKY HORROR THREE B. AND
RUSHED FOR FIFTY SEVEN B. PLANS
WHAT LOW COST FEE STRUCTURES
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO OFFER A ROTH IRA. THE FORUM
B. THREE BILLION FORTY SEVEN B.
PLANS ARE AVAILABLE NOT JUST
THE CHARACTERS MEMBERS THEY ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALL EMPLOYEES
CERTIFICATED TEACHERS. AND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES OF ANY
SCHOOL EMPLOYER THAT MAKES THE
PLANS AVAILABLE. AND UNLIKE
OTHER INSTITUTIONS WE DO NOT
CHARGE COMMISSIONS AND THERE
ARE NO PENALTIES OR SURRENDER
CHARGES. IF A PARTICIPANT WANTS
TO LEAVE OUR PROGRAM AND
ROLLOVER OR. EXCHANGE THEIR
FUNDS ELSEWHERE. HOW WHAT WE
ARE IS EVERY MY WE HAVE A FROM
FIFTY TO A MEMBERS ASKING
PROPER. TO CAN OUR ROLE ARE
TRAPPED STIRS IRAQ. THE END OF
THE COUNTER IRISH NOT THE
PROJECT TO USE IN LIEU OF A FOR
THREE B. OR FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
PLAN. BUT IT'S RATHER MEANT TO
AUGMENT THOSE PLANS. THIS BILL
WILL. WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHARACTERS
MEMBERS AND DEFERRED
COMPENSATION PLAN PARTICIPANTS
TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR RETIREMENT
SAVINGS. AND TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF LOWER COST HIGHER
PERFORMING. CAN SECOND ARMOR
ARE NO. THERE ARE NO COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS TO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU THAT'S THE IMPORTANT
PART ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO ON TO
JENNIFER BAKER. I APOLOGIZE
MANAGER I DON'T SOCIAL HER
CONNECTED ON THE PHONE THAT'S
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS- WHO WANT TO REGISTER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
RODRIGUEZ AB FIVE FIFTY ONE.
TAKE YOUR POSITION ON AB FIVE
FIFTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN THAT'S
ONE OF THE ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY TWO THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I SEE NO QUESTIONS. MR
RODRIGUEZ SAID GET OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME WE CAN ANNOUNCE
THAT AB SIX SIXTEEN BY MR STONE
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR MR SANTIAGO
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH
MR FONG NOT VOTING. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO MISS WHAT MISTER
WOULD HAVE AB. EIGHT FIFTY TWO
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. OF EMOTION BY
BIGELOW SECOND BY DOCTOR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB EIGHT FIFTY TWO
IS A FOLLOW UP TO MY BILL LAST
YEAR AB EIGHT NINETY WHICH
CREATED A PATHWAY FOR QUALIFIED
NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE
WITHOUT STANDARDIZED PROTOCOLS.
THE BILL SIMPLY CONFORMS
VARIOUS CODE SECTIONS TO
CHANGES MADE BY AB EIGHT NINETY
AND CLARIFY SOME ADDITIONAL IN
MINT ISSUES EXCUSE ME. THE
MEMBERS TAKEN AN ASSEMBLY BNP
NOW MEAN THAT CMA IS NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU WE WILL-
GO TO THE PHONE LINES THERE'S
NO WITNESS I WILL GO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB.
EIGHT FIFTY TWO. THE STATE
POSITION ON AB EIGHT FIFTY TWO
THIS PRESS ONE NUMBER ZERO AND
THAT'S- BILL AB EIGHT FIVE TO.
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO. COLONEL
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOT A WINTER MEMBERS. I'M SORRY
FOR USING MISTER EARLIER. MR BE
ABLE FOR THE Y. AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF A MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW IN A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRKY MAY PROCEED.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS IT
IMPORTANT BILL THAT WOULD
ADVANCE. MORE REGIONAL DIVIDE
DIVERSE APPROACH TO THE
APPROACH OF APPROPRIATION OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. IN ORDER TO MEET
THE ENERGY NEEDS OF EVERY
COMMUNITY ACROSS OUR STATE. THE
BILL MAKES. NO NEW RECOMMENDED
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE CPU NOR
ANY OTHER YOU TEN YOU UTILITY
AND THEREFORE WE RESULTS. IN
THE NEW NO NEW COSTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- WE WILL GOTO
THE BEFORE WE DO THAT I WANT TO
REPLACE THE MOTION AYE AYE IT
MISTAKENLY SAID IT WAS A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW IT WAS
ACTUALLY A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO A SECOND BY DOCTOR
CLERK. WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON A. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THE COMMANDOS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. TORNAL
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS THANK YOU KNOW THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE WILL- THAT
SAID THERE NO MORE AUTHORS HERE
THAT IF MR. UP DO WE HAVE NOW
MISTER CUNNINGHAM MISS
FRIEDMAN- BUT ALL STAR GOING TO
SPEAK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE HERE LOOKS
LIKE MISS KOREA YOU'RE
PRESENTING FOR MISTER KALRA AB
THREE TWENTY THREE IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. THE
MOTION BYE MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY. THE STATUS. YOU CAN
DO THERE OR BACK THERE TWENTY
THREE FEB TWO YOU. WHAT EVER
YOU WANT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF MISTER MEMBER KALRA
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWO THREE
UPDATES THE CAUSATION STANDARD
FOR APPLYING CLASS AA
VIOLATIONS AND ADOPTS AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE
PENALTY AMOUNTS FOR NEGLIGENT
CARE. TO SAFEGUARD NURSING
HOMES AND LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY RESIDENTS AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTES COSTS OF THE
BILL ARE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE AS
THE BILL IS SIMPLY CLARIFYING
AN EXISTING VIOLATIONS STANDARD
IMPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. USING THE
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR CAUSATION
CENTER WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROPERLY APPLY
CLASS A. A VIOLATION WHEN
WARRANTED THEREBY SAFEGUARDING
NURSING HOMES AND OTHER LONG
TERM CARE HEALTH FACILITY
RESIDENTS. ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT IS THE WAIT OF SAY YOU
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WILL GO TO THE
WITNESS ON THE LINES PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING THAT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE WHITE HIM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA WE ARE. ONE OF THE
BILL- WE TOOK WHAT LIKE. TO- IT.
REITERATE THAT SPELL SIMILAR
BILL HAVE THROUGH A CANADIAN
PREVIOUS YEAR- AND WE URGE OUR
YOUR SUPPORT- ALSO HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THERE BE ANY
THANK YOU THANK YOU AB THREE
TWENTY THREE ARE THEIR COLORS
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THE
STATE YOUR POSITION ON AB THREE
TWENTY THREE MAY PRESS ONE AT
THAT ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR
PHONE MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU- BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR FONG VOTING.
HI WE WILL NOW GO TO MISTER
CHOW ARE YOU. IN YOU'RE GOING
TO PRESENT FOR MR CHIU. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND
BY MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR STRENGTHENS
EXISTING PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT THE PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER FOR THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
THE PATIENT TO REQUEST THAT
INFORMATION RELATED TO
SENSITIVE SERVICES NOT BE SENT
TO THE PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER
ESSENTIALLY THROUGH A
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
REQUEST CALL C. C. R. HOWEVER
THERE IS NO STANDARDIZED CCL
PROCESS. SO THESE REQUESTS HAVE
BEEN VARIED AND HAPHAZARD. AND
CAN FOLLOW COMPLAIN WITH THE
STATE IF INSURANCE COMPANIES
FAIL TO ACCOMMODATE THEIR
REQUEST. BY BUT BY THAT TIME
THE DAMAGE IS ALREADY DONE. SO
THIS BILL AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
IMPROVES UPON EXISTING
PROTECTIONS IN TWO WAYS ONE IT
ESTABLISHES AUTOMATIC
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS FOR
SENSITIVE SERVICES ENSURING
THAT PRIVACY IS NOT VIOLATED.
AND TO IT EXPANSIVE DEFINITION
OF SENSITIVE SERVICES TO
INCLUDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
AND TRANSGENDER HEALTHCARE TO
INSURE MORE PEOPLE CAN HAVE
PRIVACY PROTECTED- BECAUSE THE
BILL IS JUST UPDATING EXISTING
LAW AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR HAS
NEGLIGIBLE COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. THANK YOU. AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES SO JUST PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO REGISTER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. BILL AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. HELLO FIRST ONLINE
FORTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THE FAMILY
RETIREMENT PLAN PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA WHERE.
SOMETHING ABOUT AN IMPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE FORTY NINE FOUR NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHEN MEMBER
KATELYN AGAIN SAYS ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION'S PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE IN CALIFORNIA-
EVEN IF YOU'RE YOU'RE TELLING
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BACKSTRAP LINE.
SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE. THE
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
WILLIAM BURKE ON BEHALF OF NAY
ROUTE PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE
NORTHERN ALLIANCE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE
NO QUESTIONS. THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR FONG
AGAIN VOTING NINE. THE RECORD
NOT JUST YET. ALL RIGHT MOVING
ON MISTER CALDERON IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU HAVE AB TWO EIGHTY
NINE IF A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO A SECOND BY MISS DAVIES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I'M HERE
TODAY PERCENT AB TWO EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY NINE
SEEKS TO ENSURE FAIRNESS IS
SCHOOL DISTRICT PARENT SYSTEM
ELECTIONS MERIT SYSTEMS ARE
CIVIL SERVICE HIRING SYSTEMS
PREDICATED ON ATTAINING A WELL
QUALIFIED AND REPRESENTATIVE
WORKFORCE TODAY THEY'RE ABOUT A
HUNDRED K. THROUGH TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS UTILIZE THE MERIT
SYSTEMS TO HIRE AND PROMOTE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES THESE
EMPLOYEES ARE DEFINED AS NON
CREDENTIALED SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS PARA
EDUCATORS OR CUSTODIANS TO NAME
A FEW. EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES
THE ADOPTION AND REMOVAL OF
SCHOOL MERIT SYSTEMS BY
MAJORITY VOTE OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES THIS BILL WILL CODIFY
EQUITY FOR THESE EMPLOYEES
DURING MERIT SYSTEM ELECTIONS
AND ADDS IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT TO
THE LECTION PROCESS HERE WITH
ME REMOTELY TO TESTIFY AS
WITNESS TO LARA STRAND FLORIST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO THE WITNESS.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOLORES DURAN FLORA'S
NOW REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE MONSTERS OF AB TWO
EIGHT NINE. THIS BILL ENSURES
FAIRNESS AND MERIT SCHOOL
ELECTIONS WITH MINIMAL COST AND
THAT'S OUT IN POOR WAY. FIRST
IT ENSURES THE SECRET BALLOT BY
PROHIBITING ADMINISTRATORS FOR
MARKING BALLOTS SO CLASSIFIED
WE DON'T FEEL THEY'RE BOTH WILL
BE TRACKED IT ALLOWS FORCE TO
BE USED INSTEAD SECONDLY IT
ENSURES EQUITY ON THE
TABULATION COMMITTEE BY
PROVIDING CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
THE REPRESENTATIVE. THIRTY
INSURANCE DISTRICT ELECTION
COMMUNICATIONS REPRESENT MORE
FIVE AND FINALLY IT PERMITS
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES TO BARGAIN
THE DATE TIME AND LOCATION AT
THE ELECTION PROVIDED THEM A
VOICE IN THE PROCESS. THE COST
OF AB FOUR THREE EIGHT ARE
MINOR AND A TOPICAL AND WE ASK.
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK THE
COMMITTEE. I SEEN QUESTION THAT
GETS OUT A ROLL CALL- WITH MR
BIGELOW MISTER ARE. THIS
DOLLARS E. R. ET NOT. ALL
EVENTUALLY KNOW. WE'LL ALL MISS
FRIEDMAN PERFECT TIMING ARE YOU
READY TO PRESENT. ALL RIGHT
MISS FRIEDMAN AB FORTY THREE
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER RIVAS
IN A SECOND BY MISS CALDERON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED A WIDE OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO ALLOW CITIES
MUNICIPALITIES THE FLEXIBILITY
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS. TO
HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY OVER HOW
THEY SAID SPEED LIMITS IN ORDER
TO CONTROL RECKLESS SPEEDING ON
OUR STREETS. AB WITHOUT URGENT
AYE VOTE THANK YOU WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES THERE'S NO
WITNESS COLORS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY THREE.
THE STATE YOUR POSITION AB
FORTY THREE NGUYEN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. LOCAL FIRST TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JOSHUA SHOP FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANKS WE HAVE LINE SIXTY SEVEN
SIX SEVEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SOVIET POLICE TO SHANDI
HALF OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE.
THANK YOU MA'AM CHEN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY SACRAMENTO OR-
THANK YOU. BLIND. EIGHTY EIGHT
ZERO. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GINA FOCO ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND
STRONG SPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE. SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I CAN BE RAPED ME
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING VANESSA GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
AND THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
APPLICATION OF GOVERNMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. LINE.
FIFTY THREE FIVE THREE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND HUMANITY HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PERTH NOW IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WEBER SEVEN
OTHER LINE IN Q. AS WELL. WE'LL
GO TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JEFF NAIRIKU SPOKE
ABOUT LEADERSHIP GROUP ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- I SEE NO
COMMENTS WITH THAT. IT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL WITH ME. MISTER
BIGELOW VOTING NO AND MITHALI
NOT VOTING. RIGHT ALL RIGHT WE
STILL NEED MISTER CUNNINGHAM MR
EDDIE GARCIA MISTER GIBSON MR
HOLDEN IN THE MEANTIME- WE WILL
HAVE MYSTERY OF US PRESENT.
FOR- PROTEST ATKINS. THIS ENJOY
A WERE PRESENTING AN S. B. S.
B. SEVEN WITH AN URGENCY
CLAUSE- IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTAKE THE SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY
PERCEIVE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
IN WITH THAT MOTION SECOND I
DON'T WANNA TAKE UP TOO MUCH
TIME BUT CERTAIN ONE REMIND-
ARE- THE- MEMBERS THAT. THE OF
THIS LEGISLATION SB SEVEN IS
VERY SIMILAR TO LEGISLATION
FROM PREVIOUS SESSION JUST LAST
YEAR SB NINE NINE FIVE FROM
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH PASSED THE
SENATE AND AGAIN IN THIS HOUSE
WITH A BI PARTISAN VOTE OF
SIXTY VOTES I BELIEVE. BUT
BEFORE SHE FAILED. PRIOR TO THE
END OF SESSION AS A SESSION
EXPIRED AT MIDNIGHT- THIS
LEGISLATION SUPPORTED BY THE
STATE- BUILDING TRADES BY
GOOGLE THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND COUNTY
AND- SOME HOUSING DEVELOPERS
FROM THE SAN DIEGO. AREA TO THE
BAY AREA. AND THIS BILL IS A
CRITICAL TOOL IN OUR EFFORTS TO
INCREASE HOUSING OPTIONS ACROSS
OUR STATE- THE PRESENT PROTON
ATKINS- AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY. R. NANCY KLEIN WITH
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE AND TOM-
WE HANG WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES IN
CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL. AS I KNOW
THAT TOM WAS STRUGGLING TO GET
THE NUMBER I'M NOT SURE IF HE'S
ON WILL START WITH NANCY KIND
OF TOM'S ON THE LINES WILL GET
HIM. GOOD MORNING MY NAME. IS
NANCY CALLING THEM THE DIRECTOR
OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE. AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
INCLUDING. SB SEVEN EARLY IN
THE SESSION. SAN OKAY AND AS
MENTIONED SEVERAL OTHER CITIES
HAVE CERTIFIED EIGHTY NINE NINE
HUNDRED PROJECTS THAT ARE
DELAYED. BY THE PANDEMIC.
DOWNTOWN WEST OR THE GOOGLE
PROJECT IS ONE OF THESE AND IT
IS EXACTLY WHAT THE CITY AND
THE REGION NEEDS FOR ECONOMIC
AND FINANCIAL RECOVERY OF SAN
JOSE AND THE SURROUNDING AREA.
ROGIC WILL BRING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT A TIME OF CRISIS FOR
AFFORDABLE UNITS FOUR THOUSAND-
HIGH DENSITY HOMES WILL BE
BUILT ON A THOUSAND OF THOSE
WILL BE AFFORDABLE AND DEEP
LEVELS OF AFFORDABILITY. AT A
TIME WHERE OVERALL UNEMPLOYMENT
IS 9% AND THEN FOR VARIOUS- POP
UP SUB SECTIONS OF OUR
POPULATION WHICH- ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN MOST NEED THEIR THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES ARE SIXTEEN
OR 18% SKILL- THIS PROJECT WILL
BRING OVER THE SEVEN HUNDRED
JOBS CONSTRUCTION JOBS. PAYING
PREVAILING WAGE JUST BE.
INSTRUCTION BUDGET. ONE ONE
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS I'M NOT
AMID THIS CLIMATE CRISIS AS
WELL AS WELL THE PROJECT WILL
ADHERE TO THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE
STANDARD. FOR FIFTEEN ABILITY
INCLUDING LEED GOLD ZERO NET
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS EVEN
THOUGH THE PROJECT WILL
ENCOMPASS OVER AFTER TEN
MILLION SQUARE FEET. FINALLY
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. AGAIN I THINK
THE NEXT WITNESSES TOM LAMB AND
I DO NOT SURE HE'S ON THE
WITNESS LINE WE WILL GET HIM ON
THE REGULAR LINE IF NOT AND I
THINK WE HAVE A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. IN ORDER LIMITED
MEDICAL CARE GONZALEZ SOME
WOMEN HERE. YEAH GOOD THANK
THANK BY PERSONALLY- YOUR
PATIENCE AND- BE READY FOR THE
DOGS THE TO GO NUTS BUT- TOM
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES CALLING AND DAY
OUT THE SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
PORTABLE HOUSING BILL AND BILL
BILL AUTHORIZED AUTHORED BY PRO
TIM ATKINS AS YOU KNOW THIS IS
A CONTINUATION OF LAST YEAR'S
AB NINE NINE FIVE- WE HEARD THE
DETAILS ABOUT IT NOT MAKING THE
DEADLINE. BUT HERE'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT SB SEVEN INCLUDES A
REQUIREMENT TO PAY PREVAILING
WAGE TO CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ON
RECORD ON PROJECTS AS WELL AS
SKILLED AND TRAINED. WORKFORCE
BOX. OKAY THERE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT OF ANY LIST THAT
BROUGHT PEOPLE YOU SO WHAT
HAPPY ALL THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE
I ENCOURAGE AND I VOTE AND
PLEASE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION FEWSTER INQUIRED
AS- THE DOG NEEDS. LINES ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER LEMON-
NOW THE OPPOSITION MICHAEL
COPAS WITH THE STILL BURSTING
LAW FIRM REPRESENTING STOP THE
MILLENNIUM HOLLYWOOD .COM. I
JUST WANTED TO READ THE NAME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MANAGER
ARBEL COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
MICHAEL COPIES OF THE SILVER
SPRING LAW FIRM SPEAKING FOR
STOP THE MILLENNIUM HOLLYWOOD
DOT COM IN OPPOSITION. THREE
POINTS FIRST SB SEVEN
INDISCRIMINATELY AFFORDS
RETROACTIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROJECT
STATUS. WERE EARLIER E. L. D.
P. STATUS HAD EXPIRED
REGARDLESS OF NEW FACT THAT.
WHICH HAS RISEN SINCE THE TIME
OF THE ORIGINAL E. L. D. P.
APPROVAL. THE POSTER CHILD FOR
THIS RECKLESSNESS IS A
HOLLYWOOD CENTER PROJECT THAT
PROJECT PROPOSES TO HIGH RISE
TOWERS ATOP THE SEVEN POINT
ZERO MAGNITUDE HOLLYWOOD
EARTHQUAKE FAULT. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
HAS OFFICIALLY NOW. THE ACTIVE
HOLLYWOOD EARTHQUAKE FAULTS
ACROSS THE SITE IN HOLLYWOOD.
IN MASSIVE NEW STUDY FROM THE
U. S. GEOLOGICAL SURVEY AS OF
MAY TWENTY TWENTY SHOWS THAT
THE HOLLYWOOD FAULT RUNS
DIRECTLY UNDER BOTH PROPOSED
SKYSCRAPERS AND RISKS
CATASTROPHIC BUILDING FAILURE.
IT WOULD BE UNCONSCIONABLE FOR
THE STATE TO ACCORD SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES ON A PROJECT THE
STATE'S OWN PROFESSIONAL
GEOLOGISTS ARE SOUNDING AN
ALARM THAT LIVES ARE AT RISK.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT MORNING A
PARTNERS IS A MAJOR PROPONENT
OF S. SEVEN IN ITS FAILED
PREDECESSOR LAST. YEAR AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY ONE.
MILLENNIUM PARTNERS IS ALSO
DEVELOPER OF THE LEAN IN SYNC
TOWER. OF SAN FRANCISCO SECOND
SB SEVEN INDISCRIMINATE
RETROACTIVE REVIVAL OF THE LDP
IS ALSO TROUBLING BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS ALTERNATIVE. TO RECEIVE
THIS SPECIAL BENEFIT SB SEVEN
BUCKS ENCOURAGES DEVELOPERS TO
PROPOSE A RED HERRING PROJECT.
WHILE OBTAINING APPROVAL FOR A
LITTLE STUDIED ALTERNATIVE. FOR
EXAMPLE A PRIMARY OFFICE AND
HOTEL ALTERNATIVE THAT IS
PURSUED. THE HOLLYWOOD CENTER
CUTS THE SIZE OF SO CALLED
SENIOR AFFORDABLE UNITS BY
ALMOST 50% A VISION OF A TOKEN
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE UNITS IS
TRULY OUTRAGEOUS CONSIDERING.
THAT THE AVERAGE MARKET RATE
UNITS IN THE PROJECT WOULD HAVE
BALCONIES THIS LARGEST SO
CALLED PORTABLE UNIT. YOU AND
OF COURSE YOU'RE- NOT COMPORT A
BILL. THANK YOU FINALLY SB
SEVEN SPORTS BECAUSE RECITES
THE NEED FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS PRIMARILY
INTENDED FOR STADIUM AND ARENA
PROJECTS THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AND AS FOR MY- WE GOT
A LITTLE OUT OF HAND WITH
WITNESSES WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE
WE WERE GOING TO KEEP A
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL IF
POSSIBLE PLEASE. WITH THAT WILL
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVEN STATE YOUR POSITION ON SB
SEVEN ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FOR THE FIRST
ON LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHARLES RIGHT ON BEHALF
OF MILLENNIUM PARTNERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
SEVEN. AND KIM. FIND. SEVEN
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERED WILLIAM
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING CLIENTS IN SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIANS BEING SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC I NEVER GOT
BAY AREA PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION ALTERNATE
BURKE- DENTAL PROCREATION AND-
THE HOME BUILDERS ALLIANCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY SIX ZERO. RHINECLIFF
BRAUN LOS ANGELES RESIDENT AND
PICKED THEM UP AND BOASTS OVER
DEVELOPMENTS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB. SEVEN LINE.
TWENTY EIGHT. THIS IS MARK NEAR
PERMITTED COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
THE COUNCIL THE POST TESTING
SEVEN THANK YOU. I. NINETY GOOD
MORNING SILVIO FERRARI ON
BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT.
YOU CAN'T. EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING JUSTIN ARE WITH THE
SLOCAN VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB SEVEN
THANK YOU. NINETY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS THIS IS KIND OF
OUR TEAM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE I TRADE
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
PROBABLY SUPPORTING S. B. SEP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH LINE.
EIGHTY SIX. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALL POWER ON
BEHALF OF THE ONE HIGHWAY ONE
PROJECT IN SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELL LINE TWENTY FOUR.
EILEEN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. WONDERFUL
WILL BRING THAT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO QUESTIONS
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU- MYSTERY OF US FOR
MOST ATKINS WE WILL NOW GO TO
MISTER GIBSON MISTER GIBSON HAS
AB EIGHT EIGHTY NINE ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY. MYSTERY OF US. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT EIGHT NINE WHICH SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT EMPLOYEES AT RISK
OF LOSING THEIR JOBS ARE
EQUIPPED WITH THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO GAIN EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYMENT ELSEWHERE AND MAKE
THE COMMUNITY AWARE OF THE
STORE CLOSER THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A GROCERY STORE TO
PROVIDE A WRITTEN NOTICE. OF
ITS INTENT TO CLOSE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT NO LATER THAN
SIXTY DAYS OR A HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
THE STORE. THIS HAS VERY
MINIMAL IMPACT IN A RESORT WILL
COST I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON WILL GO
TO WITNESSES ON THE PHONE WHO
ARE GOING TO SPEAK ONLY TO THE
FIGHT FISCAL ANALYSIS STARTING
WITH MR TO RICO. THANK YOU
MA'AM SURE GOOD MORNING THIS IS
A BLOW TO RECORD WITHIN THE
UNITED PUT A COMMERCIAL WORKERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS YOU
NOTED. THE ANALYSIS HAS SOME
SMALL OBSERVABLE COSTS FOR THE
MOST PART. IN PARTICULAR IN THE
CONTEXT OF RECORD PROFITS FOR
THE GROCERY STORES. AND THE
SECOND GOING TO SAY IS THAT
THIS BILL IS NOT DUPLICATIVE OF
THE STATE OR FEDERAL WORN
ACTION. IS SUPPLEMENTAL TO
ISSUE A NOTICE TO THE EMPLOYEES
THE COMMUNITIES PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES IN THAT HAVE.
EXTENSIVE FOOD HAZARDS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RESPECT FROM
ABOUT. THANK YOU MR TRICO. WE
HAVE ONE MORE. WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. I DO NOT SHOW THAT
LINE CONNECTED OKAY WITH THAT
WILL TAKE IT TO THE PHONE
LINES- ANYONE THAT WANTS
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU. TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON
THIS BILL AB EIGHT EIGHT NINE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. TURN
ON LINES IN Q. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS ACTED OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
GIPSON THANK YOU. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. MR KIDDING I'M WILL
BE PRESENT TEEN. AB TWELVE
SIXTY TWO WITH MOTION BY
MISTAKE THE SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO. WHICH
ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS FOR USERS
OF SMART SPEAKER DEVICES. THE
INNOVATION OF THIS TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY TECHNOLOGY HAS
TRANSFORMED MANY LIVES MARCH
FIGURES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
EXECUTE A TASK AT THE COMMAND
OF A WAKE WORD THIS TECHNOLOGY
HAS TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL IN
WIDESPREAD USE AS OF NOW THERE
ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
SMART SPEAKERS THAT HAVE BEEN
SOLD GLOBALLY. HOWEVER THESE
DEVICES ARE CAPABLE OF VOICE
RECORDING AND CLOUD STORAGE
WHICH POSES RISKS TO PRIVACY IN
OUR HOMES WHERE THE PRIVACY
INTEREST IS AT ITS PEAK. AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO SIMPLY WOULD
PROHIBIT A SMART SPEAKER DEVICE
FROM USING RECORDINGS OR
TRANSCRIPTIONS THAT QUALIFIES
PERSONAL INFORMATION UNDER THE
CCPA. FROM BEING FROM BEING
USED FOR ANY ADVERTISING
PURPOSE OR SHARED OR SOLD TO A
THIRD PARTY. FOR RETAINED
ELECTRONICALLY IN THE CLOUD.
UNLESS THE CONSUMER HAS OPTED
IN WITH AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT.
TWO IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THIS BILL AND THE
VERSION YOU MAY RECALL FROM
LAST TERM ONE IS THIS BILL
EXAMS DE IDENTIFIED DATA OR
DATA THAT CANNOT BE LINKED. TO
A PARTICULAR CONSUMER AND TO
THIS ONLY APPLIES TO SMART
SPEAKERS NORTHERN ELECTRONIC
DEVICES AND CELLPHONES ARE
EXPLICITLY EXEMPTED AS WELL.
THIS WILL RESULT IN MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO UPDATE
REGULATIONS RELATING TO THE C.
CPI. AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
I'VE- THANK YOU I SEE NO
WITNESSES SO WE WILL. GO TO THE
LINES IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO MR CUNNINGHAM'S BILL. AB.
TWELVE SIXTY TWO. OPERATOR.
MA'AM JERRY ABLE TO HEAR ME
WHAT MORE CAN. OKAY YEP- FOR AB
TWELVE SIXTY TO ME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ONE ZERO IN ORDER
FIRST ONLINE NINETY THREE
NINETY. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TRACING CRUISING BURKE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND PRIVACY IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
BRING IN THAT FACT. I SEE NO
QUESTIONS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU MANAGER
ALL RIGHT MR HOLDEN WE NEED YOU
DOWN HERE IN THE MEANTIME I
WILL PRESENT MY BILL. I DO NOT
HAVE WITNESSES. MADAM CHAIR
YOUR BILL AB TEN SEVENTY FOUR-
IT'S GOT A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARRILLO RIO AND A
SECOND BY MISS CALDERON. THANK
YOU AB TEN SEVENTY FOUR WOULD
SIMPLY ADD IT SIMILARLY
SITUATED HOTEL SERVICE WORKERS
TO THE DISPLACED JANITOR
OPPORTUNITY ACT THAT REQUIRES A
SUCCESSOR CONTRACTOR RETAIN
EXISTING WORK FORCE FOR A
PERIOD OF SIXTY DAYS THE
CURRENT LAW COVERS JANITORIAL
BUILDING MAINTENANCE WORKERS
AGAIN WE'RE JUST ADDING.
CONTRACTED OUT- HOSPITALITY
WORKERS THIS BILL HAS NO
ADDITIONAL FOR SOME COST FOR
LABOR COMMISSIONER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL.
GO TO THE PHONES WE DON'T HAVE
ANY- REGISTERED SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
JUST OPEN THE LINES WILL TAKE
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. WILL
TAKE- THERE IS A REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. JOHN MISTER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE GO
TO THE REGISTERED OPPOSITION-
OR SINCE WE HAVE NO SUPPORT
REGISTERED. WITNESS WITHIN
CANADA LINE IS NOT CONNECTED.
THANK YOU DON'T HAVE IT SO WITH
THAT PERSON NOT THERE WILL JUST
OPEN THE LINES FOR EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. STATE
YOUR POSITION ON AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE A LINE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
LINE
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. EXACTLY WHAT THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AND THE COURT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU KNOW FOR THE LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
FLOOR ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
SAYING NINE WE HAVE A MOTION
THIS BILL GETS OUT ON AT THE
WILL CALL. THANK YOU WE'RE
STILL WAITING ON MR GARCIA IS
HE STILL PRESENTE- JUST IN TIME.
MR GARCIA. MR GARCIA'S GONNA
PRESENT ON AB THREE NINETY I'M
SORRY. NINE EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU I'M IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND BUT
I. MR LEVINE THANK YOU. YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU FOR GIVING UP
TO PRESENT A BE NINE EIGHTY
THREE THIS ILL PRICE A LARGER
CONVERSATION CURLY GOING ON THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION ON
EFFORTS TO BILL CALIFORNIA'S
LITHIUM INDUSTRY. THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRODUCE LITHIUM
IN A MUCH CLEANER WAY IN OUR
STATE. THE ALL OTHER FOREIGN.
COUNTRIES THAT CURRENTLY
SUPPLY. THE SUPPLY LITHIUM
BATTERY OPPORTUNITIES A
STORAGE. WE DON'T KNOW WE DO
NOT HAVE ALL THE CURRENT. REAL
TIME ANSWERS FOR. THIS NEW
POSSIBLE INDUSTRY BUT WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DO IS SET THE
PARAMETERS IN TERMS OF HOW THE
WORK FORCES INTEGRATED. THE
IDEA OF PLA'S- THAT IT COULD
ACCOMPANY THIS TYPE OF LARGE
INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPMENT. AND
MORE SPECIFIC AB NINETY THREE
WOULD REQUIRE AGENCIES
ADMINISTERING PUBLIC FUNDS. TO
EXPAND THE USE OF COMMUNITY
WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS ON LARGE
SCALE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
RELATED TO. THIS POTENTIAL
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU- MR GARCIA WAY
I THINK YOU HAVE A WITNESS AND
SUPPORT BE JOHN WHITE. WE'LL GO
TO THE WITNESS. I DON'T SHOW
THAT LINE CONNECTED ALL RIGHT
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO SUPPORTERS
OUR OPPONENTS OF AB NINE EIGHTY
THREE JUST STATE YOUR POSITION.
STATE YOUR POSITION ON AMY NINE
EIGHTY THREE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR PHONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
NIELSEN MARKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE REMAIN INTO A CORE IF
AMENDED POSITION AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
SECOND LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. LINE FORTY FOUR. ME I
HAVE LOST LINE FORTY NORTHERN
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE. NO
QUESTIONS. MR GARCIA THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR
FONG NOT VOTING. MR HOLDEN.
WELCOME THE COMMITTEE. MR
HOLDEN HAS AB TWO TWENTY NINE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON. WHILE YOU'RE GETTING
UP THERE- MR HOLDEN I LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL INDEED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY NINE A BILL
THAT PROHIBITS A PERSON
REQUIRED TO BE. A REGISTERED.
RE REGISTERED AS A SECURITY
GUARD FROM CARRYING OR USING A
FIREARM OR BATON UNLESS THE
SECURITY GUARD IS AN EMPLOYEE
OF A PRIVATE PATROL OPERATOR
LICENSEE. OR AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
STATE. AB TWO TWO NINE WOULD
ADD THE APPROPRIATE USE OF
FORCE TO THE TRAINING COURSES
WITHIN THE PRIVATE SECURITY
SERVICE ACT. INCLUDING TRAINING
ON THE USE OF OBJECTIVELY
REASONABLE FORCE. DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES. IMPLICIT AND
EXPLICIT BIAS AND CULTURAL
TRAINING. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE COURSE
IN THE CARRYING AND USE OF
FIREARMS TO INCLUDE TRAINING IN
THE APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN- I SEE NO
WITNESSES BUT WE WILL GO TO THE
FRONT LINE SEE IF THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. AB TAKE YOUR
POSITION ON. SORRY MANAGER AND
AB TWO TWENTY NINE WE'RE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'LL AGAIN FOR BILL
AB TWO TWENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETY THREE NINE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI AGAIN THIS
IS TRACY ROSENBERG CALLING ON
BEHALF OF OPEN PRIVACY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TOMORROW
THANKS. THANK YOU NO OTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN WE JUST HAD A-
THE REPORTING OF EIGHTY
UNNECESSARY DEATH BY A SECURITY
OFFICER AND- OUR REGIONAL-
TRANSPORTATION. MTS IN SAN
DIEGO SO THIS IS A TIMELY AND
IMPORTANT BILL AT THE USE OF
FORCE IS NEEDS TO BE EXTENDED
TO THOSE WHO ARE. ACTING AS
QUIET SIGH POLICE OFFICERS AS
WELL SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IN
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN ALL RIGHT
THAT. CONCLUDES OUR REGULAR
COURSE OF BUSINESS WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR OF
A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW A
SECOND BY MISS DAVIES. AFTER.
WITHOUT CAN YOU PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SURE. AB ONE
EIGHT BALLOON MAYBE SIX NINE
ONE SHOWER BEFORE SEVEN TO
COOLEY AB EIGHT THREE ZERO
FLORA AB FOUR SIX EIGHT
FRIEDMAN AB TWELVE EIGHTY IRWIN
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IRWIN
AB THIRTEEN SIX SEVEN LOW AB
FORTY FIVE MATHIS AB FOUR FOUR
TWO MAYES. SB SIX EIGHT NINE
PETRIE-NORRIS AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS AB SIX FOUR
THREE RAMOS AB SEVEN NINE EIGHT
RAMAS AB NINE SEVEN FOUR
THREE OF US AB NINE SEVEN FIVE
THREE OF US AB FIVE THREE SIX
RODRIGUEZ AB FIVE EIGHTY
RODRIGUEZ AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE RODRIGUEZ AB FOUR OH
SEVEN SALAS AB TWO SIXTY STONE
AB TWELVE EIGHTY THREE STONE.
EIGHTY SIX NINE FOUR COMMITTEE
ON PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION AB THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS. AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY.
THANK YOU I'M AT THIS- THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU I'M AT THIS TIME WE WILL
READ THE BILLS THAT ARE BEING
MOVED TO OUR SUSPENSE CALENDAR.
MR SECRETARY AB SIX ONE FOUR
AYE YOUR CURRY EIGHTY SIX TWO
FIVE ARAMBULA AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN BAUER QUE HAN AT AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX ARCHAEON. AB
NOT FOR ONE BENNETT AB ONE ONE
ONE ONE BERMAN AB TEN OH NINE
BLOOM AB TWELVE FIFTY CALDERON
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
CALDERON AB NINE THREE SEVEN
CARILLO. AB ELEVEN SEVEN ON
CARILLO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
SURVIVED DAYS AB TWELVE OH TWO
CERVANTES SB EIGHTY FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE CERVANTES AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT CERVANTES AB
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN CHAO AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO CHAO. AB FOUR
ONE CHIU AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
CUNNINGHAM AB ELEVEN OH THREE
DOLLARS. EVEN FOR AB FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE DALY AB TEN TWENTY
THREE FLOOR AB THREE FOUR THREE
FONG. AB NINE SIX SEVEN FRAZIER.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN FRAZIER
AB FIVE NINE TWO FRIEDMAN AB
TEN TWENTY FRIEDMAN AB THREE
NINE SIX GABRIEL EIGHTY NINE
SEVEN SEVEN GABRIEL HAVING
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO GABRIEL. AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY GABRIEL AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR GABRIEL A
BRIEF THIRTY THREE THIRTEEN
CRISTINA GARCIA AB FIVE ONE
CRISTINA GARCIA. SB SIX SIX
FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA A. B. SEVEN
TEN EDUARDO GARCIA. AB FIVE
FOUR NINE GIPSON THE B. SIX
FIVE ONE GIPSON THE B. SEVEN
FOUR LORENA GONZALEZ AB TWELVE
ONE TWO THREE LEARNING AND
SALAS. EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
LEARNING IS ALL AS AB SEVENTY
THREE GRAY AB FOUR SEVEN NINE
GRAYSON. AB SIX SEVEN SEVEN
HOLDEN AB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
HOLDEN AB TWO SIX EIGHT IRWIN.
AB FOUR ONE ONE IRWIN EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY JONES SAWYER. AB
FIVE SEVEN TWO KALRA AB ONE TWO
FOUR KAMLAGER. A. B. THIRTY ONE
LACKEY AB NINE NINE EIGHT
LACKEY AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT LEAD
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT LEVY. AB
THREE ONE EIGHT LEVINE. A. B.
EIGHT ONE FOUR LEVINE AB TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR LEVINE AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY LEVINE AB FIFTY THREE
LOW AB THREE NINE SEVEN MAYES.
AB TEN TWENTY ONE MAYES AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE MCCARTY AB
NINE TWO SEVEN MEDINA AB THIRTY
FOUR MIGHT SU CHI AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN MURATSUCHI. AB NINETY
SEVEN THIS AREA AND AB SEVEN
FIVE TWO NAZARIAN AB SEVEN FIVE
O'DONNELL AB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
PATTERSON AT TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
PATTERSON. AB FIVE NINE THREE
PETRIE-NORRIS AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SIX PETRIE-NORRIS. AB TWO EIGHT
SEVEN CORK AT FIFTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT QUIRK AB THREE NINE THREE
REYES. AB FOUR THREE EIGHT RAY
IS AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE RAY
IS. AB FOUR SIX THREE OF US AB
TWELVE R. SEVEN THREE OF US AB
TWO EIGHT FOUR ROBERT RIVAS A.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
RODRIGUEZ. AB FOUR NINE NINE
BLANCA RUBIO AB TEN FIFTEEN
BLANCA RUBIO AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT BLANCA RUBIO AB SIXTY
EIGHT SALAS AB TEN THIRTY FIVE
SALAS. AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
SANTIAGO AB TEN TWENTY SIX
SMITH. AB THREE FIFTEEN STONE
AB FOUR TWO FOUR STONE AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AB
FOUR ONE EIGHT RIGHT ARE IS AB
FOUR SIX ONE V. APPROVED WHAT.
AB ELEVEN SIX TO BE APPROVED BY
AB TWO TO TWELVE TWENTY FIVE
WALDRON AB TWELVE FOUR WEEKS.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE WICKS AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT COMMITTEE
ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND AB.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT COMMITTEE
UNDER JUDICIARY. THANK YOU SO
ALL OF THOSE- SUSPENSE BILLS AS
THE AUTHORS AND WAIT
PRESENTATION SMARTLY- AND SO
NOW WHAT WE'LL DO AND I JUST
WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THOSE
WILL BE DISPENSED OF ON MAY THE
TWENTY EIGHTH I ALSO WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE- WHO ARE
CURRENTLY TEXTING ME THAT. AT
ANY ANY BILLS THAT COST MORE
THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AS TOLD TO US WE PUT ON
THE SUSPENSE FILE SO. THAT IT
IT'S WE PLAYED STRAIGHT DOESN'T
MEAN YOUR BILL IS GOING TO DIE-
IT COULD THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT
WELL- THAT BEING SAID IF THERE
IS ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
TO ANY OF THOSE BILLS THAT WERE
JUST CALLED OUT- WILL TAKE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW. YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL'S LISTED
ON THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR IN
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE ONE THREE
ONE HUNDRED THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MARDI MATIN SUR MEMBERS
CUSTOMER. PARK THAT REQUEST YOU
CENTER MALL ALREADY. SUPPORT OF
AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE I THANK
YOU FOR THE CALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I AM. FORTY NINE
FOUR NINE. CAN MEMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ THE CORBIN AND KAISER
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
TO FORCE DOWN AND AB ONE ZERO
TWO ZERO FRIEDMAN AND ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT ONE FOUR. LEVINE THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE. TWENTY
FOUR TWO FOUR. ALLEN BOGEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS SPEAKING ON MY
OWN BEHALF IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FOUR MURATSUCHI THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
FIVE SEVEN FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WOMAN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF. SEVERAL
CLIENTS ON THE PHONE WHEN BILL
AB ONE TWO THREE- NAY ROUTE PRO
TOUR CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE SIX SEVEN WITHOUT
THE MINISTRY TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AND AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BY. NINE THREE NINETY THREE.
YES GOOD MORNING TRACY
ROSENBERG CALLING ON BEHALF OF
OPEN PRIVACY IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOLLOWING BILL AB EIGHT ONE
FOUR. LEVINE AB THREE FOUR
THREE FONG AB ONE TWO FIVE TWO
CHAU AND EIGHTY NINE THREE
SEVEN. RUBIO THANKS. THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE. FORTY SIX FOUR
SIX. MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WILL PROBABLY-
SPONSOR AB THREE ONE THREE A
BILL THAT PREVIOUSLY PASSED ON
A ROLL CALL IN ANOTHER VERSION
WE ALSO SUPPORT AB FOUR ZERO
ONE AND AB FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
TWO. I ONLY A GRIPPING WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT AS EIGHTY NINE NINETY
EIGHT MACKEY AT FORTY SIX RIVAS
AND. EIGHTY THREE NINE SEVEN
EIGHT. WE HAVE LINE FORTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIRTY ARE SORRY
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION CALLING
ON THE OPPOSITION. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHT AND THE PORK BELLY IN B.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU.
BLIND. TWENTY SIX. AND DRAGON
CARROTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETY SEVEN EIGHT AB NINETY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE HEREBY
SOMETHING AMEND THE SYRIAN AND
I'LL SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTY
TWENTY FIVE LIMON SOMETHING.
NEXT TRIP LINE EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT NINE. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBER MODELING COOPER FROM THE
OF THE MARKS WERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY FIVE
O'DONNELL AND ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE THIRTY SEVEN CORREO.
THANK YOUNG. LINE. NINETY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
RUNNING OUT OF GAS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS TO ANY
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF THE
EIGHT ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE. EIGHTY ONE
EIGHT ONE. YEAH THE I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO
TWO FOUR I'M A MEMBER OF.
SEVENTY NINE AND A LOT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LEVINE. THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
BRIANNA WILLIS ON BEHALF OF THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM CENTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX
RETEST THANK. THANK YOU. LEVINE.
SIXTY FOUR SIX FOUR. ROUSE
BLACK WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA TATE EMPLOYEES- CO.
AND STRONGLY SUPPORTING AB
THREE THIRTEEN. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE ONE OH FOUR. MORE
THAN ACTUAL WALKING DISCOUNT
OPPOSITION OR MAYBE SEVEN FIVE
DOLLARS. RIGHT EIGHTY NINE
FRAZIER IN A. ONE THOUSAND NINE
THANK. THANKS WE HAVE LINE ONE
ON SIX. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS QUINN VERY CONVIVIAL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BY. NINETY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING TURBINES LAWS ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AND
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN BY
MEDINA THANK YOU. QUINE. THIRTY
FIVE THREE FIVE. YES MY NAME IS
PETER HERNANDEZ- WITH FAMILIES
UNITED TO END OF LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR LEVINE. M.
LINE. EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JORDAN SENSE OF
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
USED CONNECTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI FORTY SIX THIS
REPORT THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE.
NINETY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS KIND OF ALL CAME CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA STATE I
TRADE COUNCIL WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT OF AB TEN TWENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE. EIGHT
YES THERESA BRENNAN PRESIDENT
OF THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
LINE THIRTY THREE ZERO.
RESEARCH WORLD CAUCUS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FOUR BY
MARIA TOUCHY. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE OH FIVE. GOOD
MORNING JUSTIN ARE WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO AND HAVE A
SUPPORT POSITION ON A BEAT NINE
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT IN LINE AT ONE OO EIGHT.
EILEEN COLLINS. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR LEVINE THANK YOU. I
KNOW FOR THE LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU- AND THANK YOU MR PRATER
FOR DOING SUCH A GOOD JOB THANK
YOU FOR THE COLORS FOR ALL
ABIDING BY THE RULES AND THANK
YOU TO OUR GREAT COMMITTEE. IT
IS ADDRESS.